primer cara a cara de Vladimir Putin Y
si jinpin desde el inicio de la invasión
rusa Ucrania un momento propicio para
manifestar afinidades
el tándem de política exterior entre
Moscú y Beijing juega un papel clave
para garantizar la estabilidad global y
regional
Putin agradeció además lo que llamó una
posición equilibrada por parte de china
en torno al conflicto en Ucrania al
tiempo que condenó lo que calificó como
provocaciones por parte de Estados
Unidos en el estrecho de Taiwán por su
parte chi extendió la mano a su
interlocutor para trabajar juntos en el
escenario internacional
ante un mundo una época y una historia
en constante cambio china está dispuesta
a esforzarse con Rusia para asumir el
papel de grandes potencias y desempeñar
un papel de guía para inyectar
estabilidad y energía positiva en un
mundo sacudido por la agitación social
el encuentro sucedió en el conte de la
Cumbre de la Organización de cooperación
de Shangai que comienza oficialmente
este viernes ambos mandatarios han
sostenido reuniones bilaterales con
varios jefes de estado de las Naciones
asiáticas que pertenecen al grupo entre
las que destaca la efectuada entre el
presidente iraní Efraín y el líder